there's another military man who
attended the lake Queen's funeral today
the former head of the British army Lord
dannett Lord Danny great to have you
because I just I can't even imagine what
it was like to be actually at the
funeral we just heard from one of the
speakers there was clearly very moved
what was it like for you uh this was
your commander-in-chief of course for so
long
well Piers of course it was a huge
privilege to be there but you know I
think the thing that was probably
perhaps most significant
um my wife and I were sitting in the
Nave
um we were in the front row of the Nave
but as the leak Queen's coffin came by
only two three four feet away from one
one thought ah this is now really
serious this is the this is the end of
her fantastic Reign and it just brought
it home at that particular moment I mean
the service was fantastic the singing
was wonderful the Archbishop spoke well
the lessons were read well but just that
moment of the coffin passing by my wife
Kurt said I bowed I mean that's what we
should do and we just suddenly both said
afterwards oh that's the moment and uh
our toes as it were in front of us this
wonderful 70 year rain has ended but now
we've got to look forward to the future
yeah it's it's interesting I I was at
Buckingham Palace all day and I felt
that moment actually when the procession
passed by the palace and I looked behind
me and I saw the hearse coming towards
the end of the procession so it had been
like a good 15-20 minutes of procession
first and then suddenly the the crowd
went very quiet and you saw the Hearth
come and I'll just watched the hearse go
around the corner of the the big sort of
centerpiece there and come right in
front of the palace I think we're
looking at the images now and I found
that a really moving moment because I
suddenly realized that would be my
personal my last glimpse of the queen
that I would ever have and I found that
very moving actually and I think a lot
of people have been quite surprised how
emotional they felt about all this
uh appears I think you're absolutely
right and and those who then
um whether they were present or watching
on television I think when you saw the
the shots of the commercial service
um later on this afternoon and of the
new king and the national anthem was
sung you could just see his eyes welling
up when he realized that yes this was
the moment his beloved mother our
beloved Queen has now gone
and all the responsibilities of the
Kingdom now lie on his shoulders and and
it weighed up I think for all of us at
some point during the day the point
really came home that this wasn't just
theater this wasn't just pageantry this
wasn't just what the UK does best what
Britain does best this was real it was
personal and it was the end of this
second Elizabethan era
but I think we have to be positive uh
and I think of the archbishop's sermon
was absolutely right
um hope is a very important part of
today
um fantastic what a Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II has done the leadership
she's shown the dedication to duty but
we move on and
um we now have a new king uh we've got a
lot of difficulties in the country
energy crisis cost of living crisis new
prime minister we've got to move on
we've got to move forward we've got to
set our sights ahead of ourselves
um but like this sort of ancient
um Plowman who were plowing their
furrows they picked a something in the
just ahead of them and they drove their
horses towards it and that's the
straight line that they took we've got
to take a straight line to better places
and frankly we've got a new king we've
got a new permanent prime minister I'm a
political but we just got to drive this
country forward there's so much
opportunity here let's rejoice in what's
happened in the past but actually fix
our energy and Our Hope on the future
this is a great country it has been a
great country it is a great country and
it will continue to be a great country
we've all got to put our shoulders into
the work absolutely magnificently said
you're not available
um no I I will if I'm asked
well you know what we could do an awful
lot worse than having someone with your
attitude because we need a bit of
positivity and can do mentality and he
was certainly like that when you ran the
British army it's been a great uh honor
to have you tonight on this very special
occasion given that you were there in
your capacity is one of our finest
soldiers so thank you very much
and and appears thank you are we still
on yes we are yeah
yeah
um one of the lovely things was as all
the royal family came past
um Prince Harry looked in our Direction
and said to my wife hello Peppa just
wonderful that he was back
um I just think Harry is great I just
hope he's got a role to play in our
country in the future I mean it is such
a shame isn't it what's going on there
because there's clearly this huge Rift
with the two brothers there's a rift
between King Charles and his son Harry
and at the moment it seems quite deep
rooted but you do get a sense that Harry
having been immersed back into his
former life in the last 10 days it would
be it would take a Heart of Stone which
I don't think he has to not be
personally affected by in a way that may
make him think am I am I going the right
way with my new life you know constantly
attacking the family the monarchy and so
on is this really helping anybody
well I think the events of the last few
days must have had a significant effect
on Prince Harry and his wife Megan I
don't know what their private thought
processes are what their personal
Ambitions are but what I do know
absolutely is that Harry loves this
country he loved the armed forces his
time in the Army his two deployments to
Afghanistan and I was quite involved in
in both of those were absolutely
formative in his life
um
I wish him all the best I wish Megan all
the best but frankly from my point of
view and I think the British Armed
Forces point of view and a veterans
point of view we miss Harry we love
Harry
um I don't know how the future is going
to work out but I hope he's got a role
to play in this country in the future
well I hope he was listening to that
because I think coming from you that
will mean a lot to him you know my
brother-in-law actually uh taught him at
soundtirst and and said he spoke very
highly of him said he was an excellent
Soldier as indeed William was very
popular with the the other uh guys and
he he feels very sad about it too
well I persuaded Harry after his first
tour in Afghanistan when he wanted to go
back there I said Harry the only thing
you can do is go back within the
anonymity of a helicopter cockpit and
because a long story short
um he trained to be a helicopter pilot
and he was a good helicopter pilot on
all his weapons course he was the Top
Gun so he's a top Soldier blessing
um such a a great guy and all the
soldiers all the veterans absolutely
worship him he has a significant role to
play in this country somehow he and
Megan have got to find a way to balance
their lives between whatever they want
to do in the states in California but
actually he has a role to play in this
country I know he can't be a part-time
Royal but somehow there's got to be a
role for him because actually we need
him here a lot of people you know what I
think he needs it's very it's very
interesting listening to you talk
because you know him well um and you
know what he feels obviously about a lot
of the the military part of his life I
think maybe he needs a trip from you
maybe get on a plane to California and
go and talk some sense into him
well um the weather's nice this time of
year um but it but
you're absolutely right well um yeah
maybe well Pierce thank you for the
suggestion if you'd like to send me a
ticket
let's see what happens but um but
actually it's not for me to determine
his life and his family's life he's got
his own issues but all I all I'd say is
that he has played a significant role in
this country I hope he continues to find
a way to play a significant role in this
country within the sort of wider Environ
of the royal family
um but it was just great to see him here
today and um yeah well you know been a
fantastic day a tragic day a sad day but
we have to move forward and King Charles
III God Save the King well done it what
a what a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you very much indeed
thanks peers